welcome back I'm sorry I I was actually
I had to take a five-second pause
because something came up but let me
continue problem number 10 problem
number 10 so let's see they say that
this is X degrees so there's a formula
for the angles inside of a polygon what
I'm going to do is derive it for you
because frankly on an exam you can it's
very easy well later in life it's very
easy to forget everything so let's say
so what I do is I we know that all of
the angles are congruent right so if we
know that this is let's call this this
angle is y then this is angle is gonna
be Y this is going to be Y that is y
that's Y that's Y that's Y that's Y
that's Y that's Y right all of these
angles are the same and what do we know
about these angles here
let's call that this is Z Z Z Z there
are five of these angles and what are
they going to add up to be well they go
around a circle right so these five z
angles are going to have to add up to
360 degrees so we could say 5z is equal
to 360 degrees z is equal to let's see 5
goes into 360 360 735 1072 so Z is equal
to 72 degrees so each of these Z's is 72
degrees that angle is 72 degrees what
are the y's well Y plus y plus Z it has
to be 180 right so you have y plus y
plus 72 is equal to 180 degrees 2y plus
72 is equal to 180 2y is equal to 2y is
equal to 100 108 and actually we could
solve for y Y is 54 but really we just
want to know what - why is because look
at this we're trying to solve for X X
plus 2y is 180 right X plus 2y
how did I get that X is supplementary
with y and y this is - I write here and
all together they're supplementary so
that's where I get X plus 2y is 180
we know what 2y is it's 108 X plus 108
is equal to 180 X is equal to and
actually it's interesting X is going to
be equal to Z right X is 72 degrees and
that is choice C and that actually is
interesting that X is the same as Z and
actually when you think about it it
makes sense right because Y plus y plus
Z is 180 and here y plus y plus X has to
be 180 so X is going to be equal to Z
you say there are 360 degrees in the
circle divided by the number of Z's
there are 1 2 3 4 5 and you get 72 next
problem problem 11 the length of a
drawing of a tool is 3/8 of the length
of the actual tool ok
drawing is equal to 3/8 of actual if the
length of the drawing of the tool is 6
inches so the drawing is 6 inches what
is the length in inches of the actual
tool ok 6 inches is equal to 3/8 times
the actual tool let's multiply both
sides of this equation by the reciprocal
of this code right here so let's say 8
over 3 times 6 is equal to 8 over 3
times 3 over 8 a this of course cancels
out that's why I multiplied by the
reciprocal and this this becomes a 2
this becomes a 1 right 8 times 2 is 16
so the actual tool is 16 inches and
that's choice C next problem problem 12
I might have space to do it here problem
if X plus 3 over 2 is an integer so
they're saying X plus 3 is divisible by
2 right because in order for this to be
an integer and so what do we know about
X well X plus 3 has to be an even number
right so how can we get in because this
is divisible by 2 so that must that
means that X has to be an odd number how
do I know that so I know that X plus 3
is even X plus 3 is even I know that X
plus 3 is even if X plus 3 is even then
I know that X is odd why is that if I
because 3 is odd the only way if I had
one number plus an odd and I get an even
this number has to be odd as well to
odds added together equal and even right
for example like 5 plus 3 is 8 or 11
plus 3 is 14 right so this an odd plus
an odd isn't even so this has to X has
to be odd so when we look at the choices
right we have C choice e X is an odd
integer that's the only thing that we
can really assume based on this and
that's because X plus 3 has to be even
and anything plus an odd and you get an
even that thing that you added to the
odd has to be odd as well and you could
try it out with numbers next problem
problem 13 all right and the ex-wife
plane above points Q and s are the
Centers of the circle which are tangent
to the x axis again let me see if I can
if I can draw this so this is the y-axis
that's the x axis and now they draw a
couple of circles a small one and a big
one small circle looks something like
that
small circle in the big circle doesn't
touch the small circle so the big circle
big circle looks something like that
fair enough let's see this is point Q
this is point a those are the Centers
and they tell us at this point right
here it's 3 comma 6 this point up here
it's 11 comma 10 know what L said that's
point R this is point P Q ass oh and
then one last thing they draw a line
here draw a line here in both cases they
say this is a perpendicular
all right let's the problem in the XY
plane above points Q and s are the
Centers of the circle which are tangent
to the x-axis right they just barely
touch the x axis right here notice the x
axis what is the slope of line Q s what
is the slope of line Q s so what is the
slope of this line line Q s and it can
go further out like that go further in
this direction like that alright so we
really just have to figure out the
coordinates Q and s so Q is the center
of this so it's tangent to the x-axis
this entire diameter has what height
what height 6 so this is this is the
point 3 this is 3 6 so what's this
what's the point this Q gonna be the X
is definitely going to be still be 3 and
the Y is going to be halfway to this top
point
well what's halfway to 6 that's 3
similarly at this point this is point
11 comma 10 so the x coordinate is 11
and this y coordinate is 10 so what's
the coordinate of s gonna be the x
coordinate is of course still going to
be 11
and the y-coordinate is gonna be halfway
to ten what's halfway to ten it's five
so what's the slope slope is change in Y
over change in X so let's take the Y's
it's five minus three what five minus
three over 11 minus 3 that equals 2 over
9 right 1111 my own oh sorry 2 over 8
see I always mess up on that step well
11 minus 3 is 8 so 2 over 8 and that
equals 1 over 4 and that is choice B
I'll see you in the next video